luc chatel vice-président délégué
désormais de l'ump toujours ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale est
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
pour commenter bien sûr la crispation
autour du mariage gay et puis la
décrispation qui reste à prouver un à
l'ump
andrea bambino de l' agence
france-presse votre partenaire et puis
le père internautes de public sénat nous
rejoindrons tour à tour d'abord luc
chatel à quelques jours de la
manifestation parisienne enfin et la
mobilisation et nationales des opposants
au mariage pour tous vous votre
opposition personnelle ne va pas vous
conduire à descendre dans la rue
pourquoi moi j'ai expliqué à plusieurs
reprises ma position je suis favorable à
une évolution des droits des couples
homosexuels et je défend d'ailleurs une
proposition de loi qui a été rédigé par
mon collègue daniel fasquelle député du
pas de calais sur une alliance civile
sur l'idée de faire évoluer les droits
civils des couples homosexuels
l'amendement et ont réservé mardi soir
et nous présenteront demain matin cette
proposition de loi
mais je souhaite réserver le mariage à
des couples hétérosexuels je vois pas
favorables à l'adoption n'est pas dans
la rue c'était ma question parce que
suis je crois je crois que ce sont des
sujets très personnel sur lesquels
chacun trouve ce moyen d'expression
voilà je pensais pas la place d'un
parlement
je suis je n'adhère pas à cette idée je
pense qu'au contraire les parlementaires
ont toute leur place
par le passé il ya eu des rendez vous
importants de manifestations de
parlementaires y compris de droite je
pense évidemment au grand moment de
rassemblement pour défendre l'école
libre donc moi ça me choque pas du tout
je pense que l'ump ait toute sa place
mais à titre personnel j'ai d'autres
moyens d'expression j'organiserai des
débats dans mon département dans ma
circonscription et je présenterai donc
cette proposition a toléré sur une
évolution du droit civique mais je pense
qu'il y aura un vrai retentissement
parce que je sens une vraie émotion et
surtout une méthode du gouvernement qui
ne convient pas à inventer de l'enjeu
mais quand même le fait de ne pas
rejoindre les manifestants dans la rue
c'est une sacrée différence avec votre
président jean françois copé parce que
votre mentor jean l'aider à mener ce
combat avec lui enfin
l'année dernière thé j'ai soutenu jean
françois copé je pense que le président
de l'ump non non je pense que c'est
d'abord encore une fois sur des sujets
de société
chacun s'exprime comme il le souhaite
nous avons d'ailleurs une liberté de
vote au sein du groupe ump
pour ce projet de loi est ensuite jean
françois copé a des convictions bien
armés alors donnons nous avons chacun
des convictions et il est plus convaincu
au point d'aller dans la rue ils n'ont
simplement il pense que c'est un bon
moyen de se mobiliser face au
gouvernement et je pense qu'il va d'un
coup de monde d'ailleurs dimanche par
des arrière pensées politiques en
quelques heures
non c'est vraiment parce que c'est un
projet de clients c'est une réforme qui
va empêcher le vote de cette mesure que
nous considérons comme inadaptée à la
société d'aujourd'hui voilà je vais lui
à une évolution des droits des couples
homosexuels vers une à lyon à l'aller
juin et non au mariage que nous
souhaitons réservée aux couples
hétérosexuels est que ça ne correspond
pas à l'évolution de la société et
pourtant un sondage ifop pour le pèlerin
magazine 1 montre que les français sont
pour le mariage homo à 60%
je sais ce que c'est un combat d'arrière
garde que vous mais nous ne menons pas
encore une fois certains voudraient
caricaturer l'image et la position de
l'ump parce que et j'ai vu d'ailleurs
des propos très très choquant on sera
jugé
j'ai vu par exemple ce que vous vous
choquer beaucoup ces nouveaux propos
myhrer va voir mais quand tu joues
rondes le sentiment que parce qu'on
serait contre le mariage homosexuel on
serait y compris homophobes vont se
reposer
absolument pas nous défendons là il ya
il ya beaucoup d'homophobie chez
certains opposants au mariage gai on le
voit sur un site en blanc car ils ne
sont pas à l'ump valérie a toujours
défendu des positions qui sont des
positions contre l'homophobie
j'ai moi même au ministère d'éducation
nationale promu un enseignement une
sensibilisation à l'homophobie dès le
plus jeune âge parce que c'est un vrai
sujet chez les jeunes hommes chez les
jeunes filles dans officiellement c'est
l'un des arguments qui est mis en avant
par votre successeur vincent peillon
quitté attention à ces débats que veut
organiser l'enseignement catholique
d'ailleurs on parle de l'enseignement
catholique mais j'ai l'impression que
les établissements concernés sont assez
peu nombreux finalement attention à ne
pas stigmatiser les homosexuels à
travers ce débat sachant que les les
écoliers et les scolaires les
adolescents homosexuels ont un taux de
suicide beaucoup plus élevé oui mais
précisément je trouve ce raccourci
extrêmement choquant le musée ducation
nationale laisse penser par ces propos
que de par l'attitude et les débats dans
les établissements dans l'établissement
scolaire
on pourrait avoir une augmentation du
nombre de suicides chez les jeunes c'est
scandaleux de prononcer de tels propos
ensuite je trouve un peu curieux que un
gouvernement qui accepte que dans tous
les établissements publics
on organise des débats sur des sujets
divers et variés je ne vous citerai pas
le nombre d'associations partenaires de
l'éducation nationale qui organise des
sensibilisations des débats dans les
lycées et qu'on refuse sur un sujet
aussi important que l'avenir de la
famille de son organisation que le
mariage homosexuel on refuse des débats
dans nos établissements scolaires bien
qu'il ne s'agit pas de débat en l'espèce
par exemple le responsable de
l'enseignement catholique monsieur de la
barre a persisté et a signé aujourd'hui
un
mise au point devant la presse et on
comprend bien qu'il ne veut pas
organiser des débats il le dit lui même
il pose comme postulat qu'il faut
s'opposer à ce mariage pour tous non
mais vous voulez il faut bien expliquer
à nos téléspectateurs que l'état la loi
debré en gros qui prévoit la mise en
oeuvre des établissements privés sous
contrat
elle ya un principe fondamental qui est
le contrat d'association mais qui est
aussi le caractère propre c'est à dire
que dans les établissements privés sous
contrat
on ne fait pas qu enseigner les
programmes de la république ont transmis
obligé va leur a rendu un sujet et se
passe très bien depuis 50 ans et je
rappelle qu'à 20% des élèves qui sont
dans les établissements privés sous
contrat et que le service
l'établissement privé ce contrat fait
partie intégrante du service public de
l'éducation nationale simplement on doit
respecter et le ministre en premier lieu
son caractère propre de chaque
établissement c'est à dire l'arrêt
complet mais ça va pas être insensible
le ministre dans l'exemple en étant
associés dont le mélange en application
non elle n'a pas évolué considère que
quand on est associé au service public
de l'éducation nationale eh bien on doit
s'interdire une approche
confessionnelles et partisane mais
attendez il ne s'agit pas d'enseigné de
contrôler ces disciplines il s'agit de
transmettre des valeurs il s'agit d'un
projet éducatif qui est d'ailleurs
choisi par les familles si les familles
choisissent délibérément d'inscrire
leurs enfants dans un établissement
mairie aujourd'hui sur la base d'un
projet dénoncent le projet
d'établissement et mentalisation 1 aura
face à aris est arrivé écoutez on peut
trouver la musique oui écoutez trouvez
moi des exemples
regardez le nombre d'élèves qui sont
dans les établissements privés sous
contrat
regardez la façon dont ça se passe
depuis 50 ans maintenant dans la loi
debré et moi je regrette qu'on soit dans
une logique d'affrontement
on veut ressusciter on voudrait
ressusciter la guerre scolaire qu'on ne
s'y prendrait pas autrement
je vous rassure convenu mode de garde
scolaire oui mais ça n'est pas comme
référence à ce sont les paroles
moi je regarde les actes et
en aller dans le sens de ce que vient de
faire le ministre d'éducation nationale
demandé au recteur de dénoncer j'allais
dire les mauvais chefs d'établissement
c'est à dire ce qu'ils organiseraient
des débats qui serait contre l'avis du
gouvernement
alors d'un côté on veut enseigner de
manière précoce la philosophie à prendre
le débat à nos lycéens et de l'autre on
refuse un débat sur un sujet aussi
important que l'avenir de la famille
dans notre pays mais dans quel monde
vivons nous je pose la question
voilà donc là il ya un clivage claire et
nette entre vous et vincent peillon il y
en ad'autres évidemment d'ailleurs vous
avez eu des mots très très dur un
concernant son action au ministère vous
parlez d'un noyautage du ministère
d'éducation nationale je juge qu'une
fois l'effet préoccupante et j'ai parlé
d'une purge oui j'aurais aujourd'hui
lorsque le mot c'est papa chaque
alternance des recteurs qui valse des
inspecteurs généraux qui changent pas
dans ces proportions si vous voulez
avoir remplacé les trois principaux
directeurs généraux de ministères trois
directeurs centraux
l'inspecteur le doyen de l'inspection
générale avant le terme de son mandat ce
qui n'arrivait jamais quatorze recteur
qui ont changé sur 30
c'est une véritable purge y compris
jusqu'au directeur de cabinet du
ministre qui a été remerciée
discrètement pendant les vacances
scolaires
donc oui nous assistons à une reprise en
main qui est une reprise en main
politique
on voit bien dans les nominations que ce
sont des amis proches du pouvoir qui
sont nommés alors que en ce qui me
concerne mes prédécesseurs et moi-même
nous nous étions interdits de faire ce
type de nomination
c'est à dire que c'était sur la base de
compétences et nous avons nommé de
nombreux recteur de nombreux directeurs
d'administration centrale qui n'était
pas du tout proche de l'ump alors il ya
des mots très durs que l'on entend
aujourd'hui concernant et contre vincent
peillon par exemple l'avocat et député
front national gilbert collard désormais
et si l'appel à l'écraser du pied gauche
ça porte bonheur voilà ce qu'il dit du
ministre vincent ce sont des propos
inacceptables
voilà je ne me reconnais pas dans ses
méthodes dans ses pratiques
vous parlez d'une purge politique
l'éducation nationale est ce que
certains élus de droite font de la
résistance contre la réforme des rythmes
scolaires il ya la moitié des communes
en france aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des
problèmes matériels bien sûr qu'ils sont
confrontés à des difficultés
d'organisation qui vont pas qu'ils n'ont
pas encore passé à la prochaine rentrée
de septembre à la semaine de quatre
jours et demi est ce qu'il y a aussi des
résistances politiques nous empêchera
pas de la résistance politique les élus
qui vont être chargés de mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme
ils constatent les freins et il constate
le manque de concertation
je note d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui même
le conseil supérieur de l'éducation
vient de retoquer le texte chargé de
mettre en oeuvre cette réforme ce qui
prouve bien puisque ce sont les
organisations syndicales principalement
qu'il n'y a pas eu la concertation
nécessaire et c'est un vrai désaveu pour
le gouvernement donc les élus locaux
mais que la moitié des communes par
exemple ne s'use pas demander est ce moi
je suis une dérogation pour un an
je suis maire de chaumont - services
sont en train d'évaluer l'impact
financier d'une telle mesure mais dans
mon département de la haute marne le
conseil général a chiffré à 800 mille
euros c'est à dire deux points et demi
de fiscalité qui va payer le
contribuable donc on voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas eu l'anticipation et il n'y a
pas eu la concertation qui étaient
nécessaires à la mise en route et on a
eu des débats sur ce que vous aviez
salubre et d'un consensus sur cette
référence insu cyrus pédagogique sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires il n'y a
pas de consensus sur le petit bout de la
lorgnette qui est le rétablissement du
mercredi matin on prend le sujet par le
petit bout de la lorgnette la réforme
des rythmes scolaires ça n'est pas la
classe le mercredi matin
la réforme des rythmes scolaires c'est
réfléchir à une meilleure organisation
sur l'année je vois que le gouvernement
a décidé de renoncer à la modification
des vacances scolaires c'est une
modification sur l'ensemble de la
semaine et c'est l'idée que au total on
répartissent les enseignements entre les
enseignements disciplinaires et les
pratiques accompagnées sorties
culturelles et autres
c'est ça le vrai sujet donne jamais là
vous devenez keynote à votre successeur
vincent que j'ai un peu cherché
la charge est quand même de l'égratigner
nommé non sur les bords je ne suis pas
de ceux qui tous les matins faut un
communiqué pour commenter l'action mon
successeur il trouve qu'en ce moment je
suis sorti du bois
reprise ce que la fusion avec le fusil
sur la question des rythmes scolaires et
sur la question
dudu la circulaire sur l'enseignement
joué parce que j'étais choqué l'accord
d'une bague gratuitement un mot sur un
autre ministre jérôme cahuzac ouverture
ce mardi d'une enquête préliminaire pour
blanchiment de fraude fiscale
donc voilà la justice va tenter de
vérifier si la détenue ou non un compte
bancaire en suisse
le ministre du budget estime qu'il va
sortir blanchi il se réjouit le sort que
vous le souhaitez par mais moi je ne
souhaite rien à personne c'est à dire je
souhaite que la démocratie fonctionne et
que la justice fasse son travail donc je
me réjouis de l'ouverture de l'enquêté
préliminaire pour que la justice fasse
son travail nous sommes dans un état de
droit
moi je n'ai pas d'informations sur ces
prétendues accusations et donc je laisse
le soin à la justice de mon pays de
faire son travail
que pensez-vous de la défense jusqu'à
présent de jérôme cahuzac utile ni nez
en bloc et en détail selon son
expression on le croyait pas aux heures
parole non mais moi je ne je ne fais pas
de procès d'intention comme monsieur
cahuzac et ses amis en ont fait à
l'époque eric woerth et je considère que
nous sommes dans un état de droit où la
présomption d'innoncence fonctionne donc
c'est à la justice et seule la justice
seulement la justice de déterminer si
monsieur cahuzac est coupable ou non
d'accord pas de tendresse parce que
j'avais quand même noté depuis quelques
semaines certaines réserves de la droite
ne veux pas l'accabler
je suis certain que nous n'avons pas été
sur la ligne du parti socialiste du
temps de la faire d'eric woerth ou
greffe et sert près d'une vingtaine de
l'ancien et du déposé à l'assemblée
nationale
regrets sur ce sujet en quelques
semaines la moitié d'entre elles
exclusivement par le président du groupe
socialiste de l'époque jean marc ayrault
alors le regretté j'aurais aimé que
monsieur ayrault et ses amis et la même
délicatesse que nous faisons aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis de monsieur cahuzac la
présomption d'innocence existe à
l'honneur jusqu'à regretter la
mansuétude exprimé manifesté par vos
amis là vis-à-vis de jérôme cahuzac
je ne crois pas qu'il s'agit de
mansuétude non à la fois on peut saluer
les compétences elles sont avérées d'un
adversaire politique en même temps est
intransigeant sur le fonctionnement
démocratique la justice fait son travail
et c'est elle seule qui décidera la
suite des événements alors luc chatel ou
regarder ce que vous avez été de
doublons apparemment peut-être pas plus
que valérie pécresse
voici donc
aujourd'hui la nouvelle direction
collégiale de l'ump après cette longue
guerre pour la présidence on en parle
avec notre confrère de la sp andrea
bambino dans un instant juste avant le
point donc sur cette nouvelle structure
aux superstructures on va dire
l'organigramme à deux têtes sandra
certes ra est ce que j'ai une tête de
doublure monsieur elkabbach définition
du mot doublure remplacer quelqu'un si
besoin
alors valérie pécresse est elle
condamnée à jouer la remplaçante dans
les faits la fillonniste sera secrétaire
général délégué de l'ump
le double d'une autre blonde michèle
tabarot proche de copé elle aussi
secrétaire général de personnes pour un
poste et pour un seul m tout ça pour que
les deux camps soient représentés c'est
la direction partagée prévue par le
pacte de paix scellé en décembre dernier
idem du côté des vice présidents laurent
wauquiez le fillonniste sera vice
président aux côtés de luc chatel une
vraie renée mexicaine pour qui
travaillèrent ensemble ne sera pas une
mince affaire
ça signifie des conseillers conditions
de rassemblement de telle sorte que
chacun qui s'exprime à l'ump que chacun
qui a envie de faire entendre sa voix
l'ump qui légitime pour le faire au sein
de la direction de l'ump puisse trouver
sa place le camp fillon veulent à
trouver sa place et ne pas faire de la
figuration
mais les copistes se sentirait plus
légitime allant jusqu'à assurer que
malgré les apparences les fillonnistes
n'auront aucun pouvoir que jean françois
copé va même tout faire pour les
marginaliser à l'ump face caméra tout le
monde assure main sur le coeur vouloir
sortir de la crise mais en coulisses
l'ambiance est encore lourde et si ça
dégénère l'ancien premier ministre
pourrait ne pas dissoudre son groupe à
l'assemblée
le rhume bien évidemment que ça a été un
moyen de pression puisque 6e route
n'avait pas existé à l'assemblée
nationale je ne suis pas certain que
nous serions parvenus à un accord
donc ça a été nécessaire très
certainement il aurait été préférable de
ne pas devoir en mer
vela mais voilà les choses sont ce
qu'elles sont donc maintenant il faut
tourner cette page
sauf qu'il n'ya pas que les fillonnistes
à contenter il faudra aussi laissé des
postes aux nonnes alignés et aux
représentants des différentes motions
l'unité de la famille ump ce n'est pas
encore pour demain
d'autant qu'il faut aussi organiser le
nouveau scrutin d'ici fin septembre
voilà andré avant meinau de l' agence
france-presse
c'est avec nos îles et châtel vents
forts et à ses chapelles bonjour jean
françois copé et françois fillon sont
vus aujourd'hui pour peaufiner leur
accord vous pouvez nous dire que les
choses ont avancé
oui les choses ont avancé d'après mes
informations
cette réunion s'est vraiment bien passé
c'est à dire dans une bonne ambiance de
confiance mutuelle et de prospective
c'est à dire que françois fillon et
jean-françois copé ont travaillé sur
l'organigramme de l'équipe qui dans les
prochains mois va gérer l'ump
voilà donc l'idée c'est effectivement
que nous ayons une direction collégiale
les termes de l'accord qui a été signé
fin décembre dernier avec des
représentants des deux candidats jean
françois copé et françois fillon ont
postes importants de fonctionnement du
parti
par exemple les fédérations par exemple
les élections le projet et autres il
faut des fillonistes à la commission
d'investiture
par exemple certains réclament bien sûr
c'est normal d'abord c'est déjà le cas
si on est il faut voir que la commission
d'investiture c'est une commission qui
prend qui comprend de nombreux élus
représentants de différentes
sensibilités et qui travaille déjà
depuis nombreuses années qu'ils siègent
et qui représentent déjà ses différentes
sensibilités
concrètement qu'est-ce qui reste à
régler aujourd'hui écoutez je crois pas
qu'il y ait beaucoup de choses à régler
si ce n'est pas fini ici l'anglais vous
n'annoncez pas un nouvel organigramme
parce que il est prévu
d'ici la fin de la semaine qu'il ya un
accord définitif sur la composition de
tous les noms l'organigramme de manière
à ce qu'il ya la dissolution du groupe
rassemblement ump que nous retrouvions
tous mardi prochain pour l'ouverture de
la rentrée parlementaire au groupe b
donc les choses là en tant que
vice-président délégué d'une peut vous
nous dites que les choses vont assez
vite le seul le groupe sera les
conditions sont réunies pour la
dissolution du groupe rassemblement ump
en début de semaine prochaine quand
est-ce que vous rencontrez ou avez vous
déjà rencontré votre doublure monsieur
wauquiez
j'ai déjà bien sûr rencontrer laurent
wauquiez c'était à la fin du mois de
décembre j'ai rencontré valérie pécresse
annonce par l'annoncé même parlé pendant
la campagne nous avons débattu pendant
les campagnes on sait partie parlait
aussi pendant la période de crise faut
pas croire non plus qu'on est dans des
camps retranchés à rester très visible
quand même il ya eu une guerre de
tranchées vous ne pouvez pas le nier
sur nos billets une période dont on se
serait volontiers passé je vous la corde
mais en même temps nous avons travaillé
dans les mêmes gouvernements sa vie
valérie pécresse et laurent wauquiez
d'ailleurs été tous les deux ministres
enseignement supérieur quand j'étais
ministre de l'éducation nationale dont
on a un tout petit peu l'habitude de
travailler ensemble
laurent wauquiez sera votre égal à l'ump
il sera vice-président effectivement
donc hot wheels vagal ou seront tournés
vous êtes vice-président délégué il est
au dessus de vous tous vous quand vous
essayez une décision vous devez vous
devez l'associé comment font ces
relations ce que c'est les pubs se
passionne les téléspectateurs il se
trouve que moi je suis disposée dans
l'église statutairement c'est à dire que
lorsque vous les statuts de l'ump
prévoient que le président élu était lui
dans un ticket qui comprend un vice
président délégué qui est numéro deux du
parti en l'occurrence votre serviteur et
un secrétaire général il a été convenu
dans l'accord consignes et françois
fillon et jean françois copé que nous
créons un poste supplémentaire de
vice-président et un poste de secrétaire
général délégué qui seront occupées
respectivement par valérie pécresse est
venue présenter à nous ce soir comme
vice-président délégué légitimement élu
bah oui parce que c'est légèrement et le
sait le terme de l'accord qui a été
signé il était
l'élection a été validée simplement dans
sa coupe et c'est dégagé ghazi
légitimement élu maintenant il n'ya pas
deux catégories des musées et maintenant
il ya une direction qui se met en place
et cette direction elle a vocation à
rassembler à fédérer pour qu'enfin on
puisse se mettre au travail et nous
avons un gros travail à accomplir qui
est d'abord celui d'être force
d'opposition
on voit bien sur un certain nombre de
sujets que nous devons être plus présent
nous avons bien sûr l'arrivée au
parlement du projet de loi sur le
mariage gay mais il y a aussi les
questions économiques les questions
budgétaires
il y à s'opposer à la politique du
président république et à préparer les
prochaines élections municipales qui
sont maintenant dans un an annoncé
demain ça veut dire que les équipes
municipales qui vont travailler sur leur
projet doivent s'organiser se structure
et donc il faut bien commencer à
réfléchir à nos investiture et à notre
projet et puis enfin il y as et j'ai
appelé à cela dans une tribune que j'ai
publié à la fin du mois de décembre a
organisé la refondation idéologique deux
parties nous avons besoin et j'allais
dire l'opposition ça sert aussi à cela
nous avons besoin de repenser en quelque
sorte la droite sur tous les principaux
sujets ce que nous sommes à la hauteur
des défis du monde d'aujourd'hui
est-ce que nous comme sommes capables de
répondre aux attentes des français
voilà c'est un meneur au championnat une
répression qu'elle contribuerait en tant
que vice-président quelques animateurs
de la sensibilité humaniste il renvoie
justement aux fractures de la campagne
pour la présidence de l'ump envers jean
pierre raffarin sur son blog hier à
parler de faire un droit d'inventaire de
de la présidence de nicolas sarkozy est
ce que vous partagez ce sentiment
jeunesse qu'à côté de cette refondation
idéologique il faut faire le droit
d'inventaire du sanguié zon nous
projeter vers l'avenir c'est à dire
travailler sur cette refondation
idéologique forcément nous devons
réfléchir à la façon dont nous avons
exercé les responsabilités ce que nous
avons fait de bien d'autres est bien de
moins bien
s'allumant il s'agit pas de faire un
procès il s'agit de réfléchir comment
notre projet doit s'adapter au monde du
21e siècle comment une grande force de
centre droit peut proposer un projet
attractif aux français et en ce qui me
concerne je serai très actifs sur ces
questions parce que je souhaite que les
idées libérales humaniste trouve une
place la plus large possible au sein de
l'ue et sévèrement terre il peut porter
sur quoi sur quel thème
il s'agit pas à l'avance de décider
quels sont les sujets sur lesquels on va
regarder on va scruter il s'agit plutôt
lorsque nous élaborons notre pensée de
réfléchir comment nous allons traiter
ces questions ces dernières années ce
que nous avons bien réussi ce que nous
avons moins bien réussi donc on voit pas
de procès mais une refondation c'est
bien réussi qu est ce que vous n'avez
pas bien réussi ces dernières années
d'abord je dis qu'on a bien réussi
l'adaptation la modernisation notre pays
qu'on voyait sur un certain nombre de
grands sujets nous avons réalisé des
réformes difficiles qui ont été à
l'époque courageuse parce qu'elles ont
suscitées naturellement de l'inquiétude
je parle évidemment à la de la réforme
des retraites
je parle de la réorganisation de l'état
et de la non reconduction de
fonctionnaires partant en retraite des
agents qui étaient difficiles mais qui
était nécessaire
on voit des exemples des ventes que nous
avons mené à bien mais encore une fois
nous devrons repenser notre projet
globalement sujet par sujet ça me semble
très important il ya des choses qui ont
été moins réussie jean pierre raffarin
lui a regretté la stratégie de clivage
de nicolas sarkozy cette droitisation
qui a eu lieu à partager ce sentiment
non saoulé
la presse de manière générale je
n'accuse pas les médias mais les
observateurs ont retenu droitisation ils
ont fait aussi par la campagne de jean
françois cau c'est le terme utilisé jean
pierre raffarin moi ce que je constate
c'est que l'ump pour réussir elle doit
marcher sur deux jambes
c'est à dire que d'un côté il faut sur
les questions régaliennes parler au
peuple de droite il faut une droite
forte une droite populaire des
mouvements qui existe au sein de notre
parti
mais en même temps on voit bien et on
l'a vu dans le vote pour l'émotion au
moment du rendez vous du 18 novembre ont
bien qu'à un équilibre il ya un autre
pôle au sein de l'ump
et ce pôle il est incarné par les
valeurs libérales par les valeurs
sociales par les valeurs européennes que
moi je souhaite défendre qui sont des
valeurs qui demain nous permettront de
reconquérir le coeur des français
justement jean françois copé a été reçu
par le conseil français du culte
musulman aujourd'hui qui a finalement
retiré sa plainte après les propos de
jean françois copé sur ce garçon qui se
fait arracher un pain au chocolat
pendant le ramadan ce que vous avez été
à l'aise avec ça vous pensiez quand
j'étais à l'aise parce que c'était une
remontée de terrain d'un élu maire de
meaux dans lesquels villes dans
lesquelles il y à 57 nationalité dans
certains quartiers et donc le devoir
d'un élu aujourd'hui c'est de faire
remonter ce qui se passe sur le terrain
ce que vivent les français j'ai lu
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'intérêt que
certains philosophes chez lui à
l'africaine crottes ne conteste pas
cette idée disque évidemment que ça
existe le racisme anti blanc évidemment
que ça existe et le rôle des politiques
c'est évidemment de dénoncer cela et
c'est de monter au créneau
ça peut dans ces propos là ils ont été
oui je n'ai pas peur de le dire un
moment caricaturer et ça a pu aboutir à
des réactions inverse dans l'autre sens
parce que les propos avaient été
caricaturé qu'est-ce qui a été
caricaturée dans ses propos jean
françois copé aujourd'hui parlent de
contresens
pourquoi ne l'at il pas dit plus tôt et
en quoi il y aurait un contrechamp crise
vous dire qu'il l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises seulement il ya un moment où
une certaine classe politique où
j'allais dire médiatico politique ne
veut pas rentrer en voilà et qu'on hurle
avec les loups et qu'on n'écoute même
plus simplement ces propos là ils ont
été reçu cinq sur cinq par ceux qui tous
les jours sur le terrain dans leur cage
d'escalier dans leur quartier
difficile à vis lorsqu'un jeu de rôle on
nous avait dit il faut être à l'unisson
de ce que disent les gens sur le terrain
à il faut je pense que le rôle des
responsables politiques c'est de
dénoncer pour mieux combattre et pour
mieux apporter des solutions
donc si vous commencez parmi des
phénomènes vous êtes mal placés pour
réformer le pays pour l'adapter et pour
apporter des solutions
est ce que vous êtes déçu par le score
de votre motion france moderne et
humaniste qui arrivent troisièmes du
vote des adhérents terrière la droite
sociale et derrière la droite forte côté
nous représentons près d'un cinquième de
l'ump ce qui est une force une
sensibilité importante car si on me
demandait si j'aurais aimé pouvoir faire
un score meilleur
la réponse est oui on est toujours déçu
quand on fait un peu moins que ce qu'on
espérait la vérité c'est que sans doute
que notre force à savoir notre capacité
à rassembler des responsables politiques
qui soutenait et jean françois copé et
françois fillon a été un peu notre
faiblesse dans cette campagne puisque le
même jour on avait l'élection pour la
présidence élections pour l'émotion et
que d'autres motions préféré peut-être
davantage ceux marqués avec un candidat
nous c'est vrai qu'à france moderne et
humaniste nous avons à la fois des gens
comme moi qui ont soutenu jean françois
copé ou comme jean pierre raffarin
mais nous avons aussi des gens comme
jean leonetti ou comme dominique
bussereau qui était avec françois fillon
qu'un problème de l'identité qu'elle ait
tous a manqué d imiter est perturbé ici
ou là mais ça n'empêche pas que nous
incarnons un courant de la vie politique
française qui est un courant très ancien
et qui doit vivre davantage au sein de
l'ump et nous allons nous organiser en
mouvement c'est à dire en courant au
sein de l'ump pour faire vivre ces
valeurs pour défendre ses idées
parce qu'en plus je suis convaincu que
la reconquête du pays par l'ump passera
par ses idées libérales et humaniste
partout dans le monde
partout dans le monde les gouvernements
de centre-droit ont conquis le pouvoir
et dirige leur pays par des idées
libérales et humaniste comment vous
expliquer le succès de la droite forte
or je pense qu'il y a jerry ya eu la
volonté de s'inscrire dans la campagne
de nicolas sarkozy a peut-être la
nostalgie muscles nicolas sarkozy la
jeunesse la force de leurs campagnes
aussi il faut reconnaître quand des
adversaires politiques en l'occurrence
fin des concurrents font d'eux des
campagnes très actives
voilà et sur le fond leur proposition et
proposé par exemple d'interdire le droit
de grève des enseignants vous en tant
que l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale à moi j'ai dû me suis exprimé
déjà pour indiquer que j'étais en total
désaccord avec ces propositions mais je
préfère que ces débats aient lieu au
sein de l'ump plutôt que à l'extérieur
et c'est ça la force d'émotion des
mouvements de la diversité de l'ump qui
a été voulu par jean françois copé elle
se rappelle que c'est copé secrétaire
général de l'ump qui a accepté de mettre
en oeuvre cette diversité qui avait été
voulue dans nos statuts en 2002 mais
jamais appliquée moi je pense c'est une
force
l'ump c'est pas le caporalisme ump c'est
pas tout le monde sur le petit doigt la
couture du pantalon
le mpc pas tout le monde pense tout le
monde pareil tous pareils c'est la
diversité y en a qui sont plus à droite
sur l'échiquier politique et on a qui
sont plus libéral européen c'est mon cas
eh bien nous avons nous sommes d'accord
sur l'essentiel mais sachons faire de
nos différences
une force on en veut encore un mot à
propos de ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure le rejet massif du décret sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires par le
conseil supérieur de l'éducation est ce
que ça condamne définitivement en tous
les cas pour la prochaine rentrée la
semaine de quatre jours et demi je pose
des questions et écouter
le concessionnaire de l'éducation n'est
que consultatif et donc c'est au
ministre décide néanmoins de sa suite
simplement pour un gouvernement qui nous
a expliqué qu'il faisait de la
concertation une étape préalable
indispensable
c'est un peu difficile maintenant
d'expliquer qui va obliger les communes
sauf exception à mettre en oeuvre une
disposition qui a rejeté par tous les
syndicats dès la rentrée prochaine et
ultime question on parle d'échec il y
aura une
nouvelles élections à l'ump en septembre
si jean françois copé est candidat est
ce que vous serez sur son ticket coûtait
septembre c'est loin et 8 mois en
politique c'est long donc nous verrons
d'avoir si jean françois copé est
candidat et ensuite écouté je pense
qu'il sera un bon président de l'ump
donc je pense que le mais c'était lui et
à lui seul et je ne veux pas lui mettre
une quelconque forme de pression donc
c'est à lui de décider le moment venu
pas maintenant donc nous verrons
travaillons mettons nous au travail dans
les conditions que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure de manière rassembler et
collégial et puis cet été on verra qui
est candidat qui fait quoi comment sont
galles avec qui d'ailleurs quel projet
bon c'est pas le moment
notre petit doigt nous dit qu'il sera à
nouveau candidat merci chers confrères
perrine tarneaud de leurs à nous
rejoindre dans un instant à luc chatel
mais d'abord et bien on va suivre ce
portrait de vous réalisé par marie
brémaud aux sources de l'engagement dans
votre enfance
tout jeune déjà luc chatel se révèle un
grand destin en admirant les posters de
valéry giscard d'estaing qui ornait sa
chambre ce fils d'une famille
d'industriels de la métallurgie de la
haute marne avait à peine 10 ans alors
quand ce jeune étudiant vient frapper à
la porte de gérard longuet pour
embrasser une carrière politique
ce dernier lui dira apprend d'abord un
métier le bon sens c'était de gagner sa
vie d'abord et surtout de ne pas être un
apparatchik quelqu'un qui dépendent des
institutions politiques des
collectivités locales ou d'un parti
qu'il puisse exister par l'humain c'est
ainsi que luc chatel gravira les
échelons chez l'oréal pendant 12 ans
de cette expérience dans le privé ils
ventilent et une grande leçon
le pire ce nom pas savoir pire c'est de
ne pas avoir anticipé
en politique cela se traduit par une
saine inquiétude et je trouve que ça lui
correspond et c'est bien c'est so far so
good
jusque là ça va mais tout peut être
revenir menacer sous ses apparences
d'homme tranquille luc chatel serait
donc en fait un grand angoissé
pas étonnant donc qu'il ait répété une
dizaine de fois son entretien avec
nicolas sarkozy en vue d'entrer au
gouvernement au président il se vend
comme le ministre du pouvoir d'achat
l'argument séduit en juin 2007 à 43 ans
il devient secrétaire d'état à la
consommation
durant cinq ans il exerce des fonctions
gouvernementales
alors est ce que la politique la changer
je pense que la politique a révélé c'est
sa personnalité sa personnalité c'était
d'être à l'homme de conviction et un
homme de conciliation il est les deux à
la fois son avenir il le voit toujours
en politique
à moins que le club du psg dont il est
fan ne lui fasse un jour les yeux doux
l'été est un concurrent aux goûts de
votre reconversion dans le foot
oui j'ai jamais vraiment songé mais les
sharks je suis passionné de foot mais
moi pdg depuis 1975 donc ça fait un
petit moment encore so far so good sa
devise c'est pas mal ça normal ouais
mais est ce que vous aimez vous
l'instabilité permanente
rien n'est jamais acquis c'est pas grave
c'est que c'est d'abord c'est la vie et
je pense que moi j'ai effectivement
beaucoup appris je trouve votre
reportage assez juste sur ce point c'est
que j'ai beaucoup appris du monde de
l'entreprise en particulier de
l'entreprise dans laquelle j'étais qui
transmet cette culture qui est de 10
cette espèce est saine inquiétude c'est
comme ça c'est le syndrome du
commandement de bord et que tous les
clignotants sont au vert mais on perd
c'est vrai que mon en bord en permanence
recalcule
ces instruments pour être certains qui a
pas eu d'erreur et pour anticiper toute
erreur possible et donc le zinc du
commandement c'est quoi c'est que tous
les clignotants sont au vert bien que
vous vous dites qu est ce qui peut
m'arriver
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas anticipé
qu'est-ce que j'ai mal fait c'est aussi
la capacité à se remettre en question
tous les matins de se dire tiens j'ai
dessiné sa fière mais est-ce que je peux
pas améliorée faire évoluer ma décision
donc je savais que le monde de
l'entreprise m'a beaucoup appris
donc le marketing de l'oréal appliquée à
la politique sa marge et les ressources
humaines se rappelle que j'ai passé 10
ans chez l'oréal mais j'ai fait d'abord
du marketing pendant quatre ans dont 28
800 de ressources humaines c'est comme
ça que vous avez pu préparer votre
entretien d'embauché le gouvernement
après nicolas sarkozy se dit beaucoup
préparé cet entretien pour entrer au
gouvernement le persuader de vous
prendre au poste de ministre ou de
secrétaire d'état à la consommation
je sais pas où vous tenez cette
information mais c'est vrai alors c'est
vrai j'en viens même enseigne et la
vérité c'est que nicolas sarkozy était
un homme de conviction et qu'il écoute
les gens et que soit le jour parce que
je n'ai pas dit c'est que vous n'étiez
pas sur la feuille de match du
gouvernement oui c'est en fait je savais
en rentrant dans son bureau que j'étais
pas et en sortant du bureau je me suis
dit j'ai peut-être une chance
comment alors comment vous y êtes prêts
non j'ai essayé de lui expliquer par
rapport à il venait d'être élu il avait
fait pendant sa campagne il avait mis
l'accent sur les questions de
consommation proximité à bercy ou si
l'on est ministre des finances sur ces
sujets je lui dis il faut quelqu'un au
gouvernement qui traite de ces questions
et voilà j'avais deux trois idées et il
a été à l'écouté et puis c'est vrai que
j'ai une relation avec nicolas sarkozy
là il m'a toujours fait confiance j'ai
une relation de proximité d'amitié qui a
dû jouer aussi ce jour-là et un
entretien que vous avez répété plusieurs
fois avant oui c'est vrai
mais vous savez avec lui ses entretiens
entre cette inquiétude avec lui ça
marche c'est à chaque réunion
vous sentez vous êtes sur la sellette
mais ça convient bien moi je préfère
être jugé sur mes résultats plutôt que
sur des part des quotas aux des
artifices hommes de conciliation disait
gérard longuet dans le sujet hommes de
pondération au risque d'apparaître
parfois un peu trop lisse
je sais que c'est le reproche qu'on m'a
fait pendant un certain temps je pense
avoir montré ces derniers temps que
j'étais capable
d'abord d'avoir des fautes des
convictions de les exprimer et voilà ça
veut pas dire oui je suis plutôt un
rassembleur et j'aime bien fédérer les
gens j'aime bien concilier oui mais
plutôt quelqu'un qui livre en permanence
mais ça n'empêche pas d'avoir des
convictions de s'exprimer de dire ce
qu'on pense que du coup voilà c'est à
dire est ce que vous êtes à l'aise
derrière quelqu'un qui qui va un peu
plus je pense à jean françois copé par
exemple un peu terne j'allais dire
peut-être encore plus parce que
peut-être qu'il a besoin lui d'avoir à
ses côtés quelqu'un qui rassemble qui
écoute et puis s'ils voulaient
l'avantagé avec jean-françois s'est
construit depuis très longtemps et qu'on
se parle très franchement voilà on je
sais qu'ils m'écoutent je sais que je
fais partie des gens quand je dis
quelque chose que voilà il réagit pas
forcément sur le moment mais il
enregistre et je vois qu'il agit alors
c'en est fini totalement aujourd'hui de
laventure de la bande des mousquetaires
c'est la bande de khadra que vous
formiez avec jean françois copé valérie
pécresse
christian jacob françois baroin mais
c'est vraiment fini
elle est la première de l'ump a laissé
des traces assez violente je pense
notamment jean-françois passé violent
s'avère moins assez violente
non bon c'est vrai c'est un peu une
désillusion alors peut-être que nous
avions trop avec votre est d'ailleurs
vous les journalistes politiques mais
trop misé sur sept en imaginant que
cette bande 2,6 c'était un vrai projet
politique alors c'était finalement
plutôt une bande de copains qui se
réunissait pour échanger sur la
situation politique du moment et
envisager des perspectives mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu des violences entre
entre certains qui n'ont les néons
rappelons-le est par exemple on peut
dire
c'est vrai que jean françois copé a été
je le dois dire atteint parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est derrière cette c'est
parfois le semestre qui peut paraître
comme un masque est quelqu'un de
profondément affectif
ils se rapprochent beaucoup de nicolas
sarkozy ce point c'est à dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui marche à l'affectif et
donc c'est vrai que oui ils pensaient
peut-être naturellement que ayant fait
une bande des mousquetaires tous les
mousquetaires à les soutenir dans sa
campagne pour la primaire de l'ump ça
aide pas été le cas
on pensait que johan solidarité d'amitié
en politique que la météo je manquais
l'amitié d'ailleurs c'est une des unes
des décisions des raisons qui m'a fait
soutenu jean françois copé il ya une qui
était très politique sur je pensais que
c'était le mieux placé comme alain juppé
pour pour diriger l'ump
mais il ya aussi l'amitié voyez moi je
le connais copé depuis très longtemps je
l'aï vu évoluer
il a une espèce de ténacité et il est
fidèle en amitié jean françois copé
s'est noyé en play en crue sur françois
fillon je ne pose pas l'un à l'autre
le jeu vous dire j'ai été ministre pour
ça que ça pas été facile pour moi j'ai
fait le choix du coeur de l'amitié mais
en même temps j'ai tout de suite appelé
françois fillon le dit ricco que j'ai
été un ministre en cinq ans jaya j'ai
rien à te reprocher tu m'as fait
confiance j'ai toujours travaillé en
confiance avec lui simplement il ya un
moment où dans la vie il faut faire des
choix ou on choisit la bonne personne au
bon moment pour le monde jo ça c'est un
match qui meurent après ça et se trouve
c'était plutôt qu'aux pays bas lors de
ses voeux au conseil constitutionnel
françois hollande a annoncé que les
présentes de la république ne siègeront
plus de fait qu'on sait qu'on cite ça
c'est une bonne initiative
non si c'est pas surprenant j'ai
justement c'est surprenant de la part de
françois hollande parce que pour une
fois il applique son programme il avait
annoncé je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne idée parce que je pense que le mot
sage prend toute sa plénitude
avec cette ses anciens présents dans un
pays je pense que quand on est un agent
siens jusqu'à un niveau jamais chirac
n'y siègent plus pour raisons de santé
alors je dirais la cm dans un sens oui
je pense qu on a tort de se priver des
compétences d'anciens près de deux
personnalités qui ont exercé les plus
hautes fonctions et qui peuvent aider
orienter la le rendu les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel voilà je trouve
ça regrettable mais on va pas se rouler
par terre et la suppression de la cour
de justice la modification du statut
pénal du chef de l'état est ce que ça
c'est des réformes constitutionnelles
que seriez prêt à soutenir je suis prêt
à les examiner voilà je pense que c'est
des sujets sur lesquels on a on a besoin
de consensus et on a besoin de
travailler entre l'opposition et la
majorité simplement je suis pas sûr que
le gouvernement prenne le bon chemin et
le présent de la république dans la
façon dont ils gouvernent aujourd'hui
alors on a plutôt l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui françois hollande est
dans une logique de division plutôt que
dans une logique de rassemblement près
quand même trouvé un petit peu de
consensus politique de gauche de droite
sur les réformes institutionnelles
le rapport jospin se rapproche quand
même du rapport balladur qui avait été
rendue sous nicolas sarkozy
j'aurais d'ailleurs visible ce concert
si j'aurais aimé d'ailleurs qu'à
l'époque le parti socialiste soutiennent
de manière massive des réformes qu'il
avait appelée de ses voeux depuis bien
longtemps il ya eu seulement quelques
personnalités emblématiques comme jack
lang à l'époque pour accompagner le
gouvernement précédent dans ses réformes
donc nous serons pas dans la même
logique d'ostracisme de ou de caricature
mais encore une fois quand je vois
aujourd'hui françois hollande
j'ai vraiment l'impression du président
qui fracturent la société qui nous avait
promis l'apaisement et on a droit à la
division regardez la façon dont il a
laissé faire jean marc ayrault sur la
sphère depardieu
regardez comment ils l'espèrent certains
de ces gouvernements certains de ses
ministres dans la façon dont il se
comporte une logique
j'allais dire presque guerrière où je
pensais que le parti suisse avait rangé
la guillotine au paquet en 1980 ils
l'ont ressortis en dessous pas en
opposant les français les uns et aux
autres qu'on sortira ce pays la crise
commencera que c'est le message que je
veux faire passer à françois hollande
aujourd'hui a été sorti du site internet
de l'elysée
at on appris oui écoutez voilà un
exemple de d'ostracisme je vous citais
tout à l'heure la purge certain nombre
de postes de la haute fonction publique
la façon dont le préfet de police de
paris a été débarqué de manière tout à
fait inacceptable alors que c'est un
homme de grande qualité c'était le
président silva préfère défendre le
dialogue devant les autorités
religieuses
à écouter on assiste encore une fois à
un double discours et un deux poids deux
mesures puisque françois hollande a fait
campagne sur l'apaisement la république
rassembler et depuis qu'il est en en
oeuvre à chaque fois qu'il se présente
une occasion on a l'impression qu'ils
divisent les français c'est encore le
cas pour ce mariage homosexuel ou nous
nous demandons des débats où nous sommes
c'est un sujet le chef de l'état a
raison de rappeler que c'est le
législateur qui était si bien sûr ses
lecteurs qu'indécis simplement on ne
peut pas d'un côté nous expliquer qu'il
faut une démocratie moderne qui est
basée sur la concertation sur les coûts
tu es sur un sujet aussi important que
l'évolution de la famille ne pas
accepter qu ait de grands débats là et
moi je regrette cette absence de débat
que nous nous demanderons au niveau
l'ump j'avais une dernière question au
vice président de l'ump sur les finances
de votre mouvement elles plongent dans
le rouge ça vous inquiète
imaginez que demain la validation des
comptes de campagne de nicolas sarkozy
soit confirmée alors vous auriez un trou
supplémentaire de 11 millions d'euros
c'est à partir ce ne serait envoyé par
en faillite mais en tout cas un parti
qui va devoir faire des économies qui va
devoir serrer la vis à tous les niveaux
monsieur aussi une bonne école pour
reprendre le pouvoir derrière puisque
c'est ce qu'il faudra faire au plus haut
niveau de l'état
merci beaucoup luc chatel d'avoir été
avec no mercy terrine ou servie
merci bonsoir à tous et à très vite
en ci a été gardée par des gendarmes
français
géré par des fonctionnaires foncez les
enfants qui ont été amenés ici de
pithiviers et beaune-la-rolande avait
été arrêté par des policiers français
la mémoire est aussi un enjeu
d'actualité
régulièrement les commémorations font
l'objet de débats et polémiques entre la
droite et la gauche mais aussi à
l'intérieur même de chaque camp alors
faut-il pratiquer la repentance tenir
compte du contexte pour expliquer
l'histoire et comment transmettre la
mémoire du passé aux jeunes générations
cette semaine des avions en tout bien
tout honneur les politiques en costume
d'historia déshabillons-les présentée
par hélène risser demain 18h15 sur
public sénat anniversaires mariages
naissances au fil des années ils ont
filmé leurs familles dans ces
appartements tout neuf où il avait
emménagé on se retrouver tous a démarré
ensemble dans cette nouvelle
cité c'était dans l'essonne et cela
avait le parfum du bonheur
nous sommes arrivés donc dans la tour en
1973 elle n'était pas encore totalement
habité et on n'avait pas du tout
l'impression de vivre dans un bel
immeuble insalubre dans un quartier pour
ils ont filmé les grands ensembles
samedi à 15h15 sur public sénat
regardez cette vue paris paris dans
toute sa splendeur pendant trois siècles
et bien ce panorama des rois des reines
des empereurs l'on contemple est scruté
par fois depuis la terrasse d'un des
plus prestigieux château de l'histoire
de france
bonjour à tous et bien ce château celui
de saint cloud n'existe plus c'est
l'histoire qui l'a détruit et seule la
végétation trace aujourd'hui encore son
architecture disparu
paradoxe c'est un hobby français qui l'a
détruite dans cette période trouble et
souvent oubliés de la guerre de 1870
tout s'est passé très vite le 13 octobre
de cette même année une année maudite
une année terrible
marie lebon juillet 1870 française et
prussiens entre en guerre une guerre de
mouvement rapide et brèves aujourd'hui
oublié ses origines restent confuses et
pourtant quelques épisodes demeure dans
la mémoire collective
la bataille de gravelotte près de metz
oppose huit mille cavaliers française et
prussiens la capitulation de sedan qui
entraîne le 2 septembre la chute du
second empire et l'exil de napoléon iii
et plus tard la perte de l'alsace et de
la lorraine lors de la signature de
l'armistice à versailles en janvier 1871
autre conséquence immédiate le
chancelier bismarck et ses troupes
encerclent la capitale
c'est le siège de paris les parisiens
trouvent refuge à l'abri des
fortifications
mais très vite les pénuries alimentaires
se multiplient on manque de tout dans
les eaux et jardins on abat les animaux
pour se nourrir et pour survivre c'est
des terrasses du domaine de saint-cloud
que l'état-major prussiens observe le
siège un quartier général à portée des
tirs des bastions français l'obus fatale
par du mont valérien et enflamme le
château après avoir été pendant des
siècles le théâtre de l'histoire
saint-cloud disparaît dans les flammes
sous le regard impassible des forces
prussienne
je rejoins sylvie glaser qui est
administratrice du domaine national de
saint-cloud bonjour madame
alors il n'y a plus aucun doute
aujourd'hui a pas de querelles
d'historiens c'est bien un obus français
qui a frappé le château de saint-cloud
oui tout à fait l'obus qui a été tiré le
13 octobre 1870 provenait du monde à
l'est rien et est tombé dans la chambre
de l'empereur et il était bien bien
français alors grecque ont dit un petit
mot de la situation de cet ancien
château paris est vraiment tout proche
mais versailles n'est pas loin non plus
bref c'est un endroit idéal pour un roi
une reine ou des empereurs oui alors
c'est vrai que saint cloud et étaient
entre paris et versailles
on passait on s'arrêtait à saint cloud
en allant voir le roi ou au retour et ce
n'est pas pour rien d'ailleurs que
c'était la résidence du frère de louis
xiv philippe d'orléans
on l'appelait monsieur a beaucoup grandi
cette cet ancien pavillon de chasse
il ya une autre personnalité extrêmement
attachés à ce château de saint-cloud
c'est marie antoinette
oui alors en 1785 marie-antoinette
acquiert le château de saint-cloud comme
biens personnels
elle y passera son dernier était elle
recevra la fayette
auréolé de ses succès de la guerre
d'indépendance aux états unis et il y
aura aussi une entrevue beaucoup plus je
dirais secrète qui est l'entrevue avec
mirabaud
il yal empire l' empire qui a marqué cet
endroit déjà le premier empire en tout
cas ses prémices le 18 brumaire c'était
ici à quelques mètres seulement dans
l'orangerie qui existait alors
exactement là effectivement bonaparte à
l'époque attendait dans un modèle dans
une des ailes du château
les deux conseils étaient réunis conseil
des anciens dans la galerie apollon du
conseil des cinq sens dans l'orangerie
il fait donner la garde les les députés
qui étaient tous en toge se précipite à
l'extérieur et quelques-uns à peu un peu
tétanisé l'été finalement vu presque
otage on va dire proclame aussi la
démission du directoire
bref essai le consulat qui commence qui
commence ici en tout cas quasiment
exactement le château de 5
c'est également le coeur le coeur
battant du second empire en quelque
sorte
napoléon iii napoléon iii a été proclamé
empereur par le sénat tu consultes dans
la galerie d'apollon et ce n'est pas un
hasard puisqu'il voulait effectivement
s'inscrire dans la tradition du premier
empire
on évoquait à l'instant la destruction
de ce château de saint-cloud en octobre
1870 le château qui reste est en ruine
pendant des années après pendant plus de
20 ans effectivement la troisième
république
exit sur l'avenir à réserver à cette
ruine belles ruines quand même si le
château a été finalement démoli en 1892
c'est aussi une décision politique il
est trop chargée des souvenirs de la
faillite de lempire chargé des souvenirs
de l'ancien régime dans cette pour cette
république encore en corner santé
vacillante
c'est un risque politique qu'elle n'a
pas envie de prendre parce que
finalement la destruction de ce château
de saint-cloud et sa non reconstruction
elle coïncide grosso modo lincendie des
tuileries à paris
des tueries qui est elle aussi n'ont pas
été reconstruits oui alors en 1883
l'écurie sont rasés en 1892 cinq lots et
rasé le château de bercy est rasé en
voit que c'est une période où quelque
part on décide progressivement
effectivement d'éliminer tous et tous
ces souvenirs un peu un peu comment dire
les charges de charge et voilà